so this was a beautiful little scene  where Bruce is kind of sitting in his  new chamber at the hospital and the  orderly comes in and they just have a  silent staring match where Pierce is  trying to kind of silently say I'm I'm  in charge here  and Bruce kind of looks over his  shoulder like I could kill you in with  my pinky and and they both stare at each  other and and Pierce has kind of  unraveled a little bit cuz he's heard a  lot about you know they've all seen  videos of this guy he's really really  strong so he's kind of like I I'm in  this place I'm in charge and it's just a  beautiful little scene the reason it's  not in it's just literally a rhythm  thing of how long can we spend on the  first night at the hospital that was the  only reason it's not in it's actually  one I'm really sad not in the movie  you  [Music]